en directo a América edición nocturna
llegó el momento de hablar de economía
por ello le doy la bienvenida a mi
compañero Jorge Hurtado Jorge qué tal
Muy bien Andrés y vos Bien también Jorge
iniciamos hablando de Estados Unidos el
presidente Joe biden propuso una fuerte
reducción del déficit fiscal de tres
billones de dólares para los próximos 10
años cómo piensa lograrlo cuéntenos
bueno piensa hacerlo principalmente con
más gasto y también con más impuestos
sobre todo con una mayor fiscalidad a
las empresas y a los más ricos biden
presentó este presupuesto de 6,9
billones de dólares que es la antesala
también de un enfrentamiento con el
partido republicano el plan para reducir
el déficit de la nación en casi 3
billones de dólares en 10 años será
mediante el aumento de impuestos a los
que ganan más de 400 mil dólares al año
se trata de un impuesto mínimo del 25%
de los multimillonarios y duplicando el
impuesto sobre las plusvalías desde el
20%, biden también quiere cuadriplicar
el impuesto del 1% sobre la recompra de
acciones lo que podría provocar un
enfrentamiento con muchos de los
inversores a los que va a necesitar
probablemente para financiar cualquier
campaña de reelección el presupuesto
aumentaría el gasto Federal en los 12
meses que comienzan a partir de octubre
hasta 6,9 billones de dólares frente a
los 6,2 billones gastados en el año
fiscal 2022 la deuda total de Estados
Unidos se elevaría a casi el 110% del
producto interno bruto en 2023 una cifra
que se compara solamente con los picos
alcanzados durante la movilización del
país para la Segunda Guerra Mundial el
presupuesto También incluye una de las
propuestas más simbólicas del gobierno
de biden ampliar la capacidad de
Medicare para negociar los precios de
los medicamentos farmacéuticos una
medida que según los cálculos permitiría
un ahorro estimado de 160 mil millones
durante una década Jorge de Estados
Unidos pasamos a México la inflación
anual comienza a ceder bueno se trata
del dato más bajo desde marzo de 2022
Aunque Existen algunas presiones
inflacionarias
con datos del índice Nacional de precios
al consumidor la tasa de inflación anual
de febrero se desaceleró para ubicarse
en el
7,62% anual una disminución desde el
7,91 que se registró en enero de 2023
pero no todos son buenas noticias porque
la inflación subyacente subió la
inflación subyacente es este dato que no
tiene en cuenta los alimentos frescos ni
la energía por su volatilidad y
determina casi siempre la trayectoria de
la inflación en el mediano y largo plazo
la inflación subyacente aumentó un 0,61%
mensual y se ubica en el 8,29 anual el
índice de mercancías que incluye el
precio de los alimentos se ubicó en
10,65% su menor nivel desde agosto del
2022 pero muy por encima de la inflación
en general los alimentos que más
subieron de precio en México fueron los
huevos y los plátanos así como el precio
del pollo en contraste algunos productos
bajaron como el jitomate y el chile
serrano para los economistas la
inflación muestra señales mixtas y
todavía no hay una evidencia Clara de
que haya una tendencia a la Baja porque
seguimos hablando de México tesla
comenzó a contratar gente para su mega
fábrica allí en territorio mexicano
bueno El fabricante de vehículos
eléctricos está buscando candidatos para
gerencia jurídica para seguridad de
construcción analista financieros y
también expertos en logística pero las
contrataciones muestran la rapidez con
la que tesla quiere moverse en la
construcción de esta fábrica la llegada
de tesla a Monterrey resalta el interés
comercial en el norte de México así como
la reubicación de empresas que buscan
estar cerca del mercado estadounidense y
evitar así los problemas logísticos de
la cadena de suministro la fábrica
comenzará su producción en 2024 y ya
mostró un primer diseño el modelo que
será utilizado en estas nuevas
instalaciones en México cuenta con la
nueva plataforma modular para los
vehículos que permite la fabricación de
variantes se dan o sub con una
estructura similar básicamente permite
hacer más vehículos en menos tiempo
Jorge y Turquía aumenta los puestos a
empresas para financiar los costos por
el terremoto bueno el país aprobó un
impuesto extraordinario a unas 22.000
empresas para contribuir a costear estos
84 mil millones de dólares en daños que
dejaron los terremotos de hace un mes la
nueva tasa aprobada la noche en durante
la noche en el parlamento solo se aplica
a ingresos empresariales y no a los
salarios y equivale al 10% del monto
total de extensiones y rebajas en la
declaración de la renta del año 2022 las
empresas radicadas en las once
provincias que fueron afectadas por los
sismos del 6 de febrero están exentas de
este pago Se alegan fuerza mayor la
confederación empresarial turca estimó
el mes pasado el daño económico de los
terremotos en unos 84 mil millones de
dólares y nuestra cifra del día Jorge
tiene que ver con México
0,7% del producto interno bruto eso
costó la inseguridad y los delitos en
México en el 2022 se trata de unos 120
mil millones de pesos mexicanos
equivalentes al cero coma siete del pib
esta cifra va en correlación con la
extorsión el robo el asalto de
mercancías y dinero los insumos y los
bienes que fueron los delitos con mayor
incidencia en ese país Jorge muchas
gracias por la información económica
ustedes televidentes también gracias por
sintonizarnos no se desconecten a
continuación el debate
[Música]